everybody's gary vaynerchuck up gary
mitrik calm i want to sort a new little
series called small fYI you know it's
like an FYI but it's small just a little
tidbit allows me to pump out videos I've
noticed there's a lot of days where I
have these thoughts I don't think
they're big you know game-changing
thoughts and I'm like I shouldn't do a
video I shouldn't waste people's time
and the same token more more people like
hey do videos and there are things that
become bigger and bigger and it's fun to
kind of talk about them early on so I'm
gonna start this little serious my first
small fYI is that I just noticed this
little bar above Facebook introducing
the like button you know starting today
they're changing the terminology on the
Facebook fan page from become a fan to
like now this is something that I knew
was coming AJ and I at vaynermedia have
been talking about this what does this
mean I think it's interesting their last
line says we hope this action will fear
will feel much more lightweight and that
will increase the number of connections
made across the site this is something
that I don't think is that minor I think
people should pay attention to this let
me show to you in real life if you were
to go to a fan page right here my little
zoomy zoom you can see now ma it's a
like instead of become a fan and now
basically I'm in their database so now
they've got me in here so now Forbes has
twenty six thousand one hundred and six
fans instead of five it has long been my
position for at least a year now it
feels like or maybe a little bit shorter
that Facebook fan pages are the most
important sites maybe that any to add to
a brand anywhere on the internet maybe
even more important their own homepage
the ecosystem of what Facebook is and
the flexibility that the fanpage allows
you to do all these creative things and
you know the virality of once it becomes
in a newsfeed is so iconic I think this
is a shift for Facebook to get more
people to feel like they can like more
things becoming a fan feels kind of
heavy like a my fan of coke but like it
yeah I like it it's kind of like like it
right it's you know it's like a hookup
instead of marriage I think it's a very
big shift I think it will increase the
amount of fan pages that you follow and
I think by virtue increases the business
ecosystem that Facebook is creating it
is quickly happening that Facebook is
becoming
nice spot for brands to go to the vanity
URL that brands want to use like
facebook.com slash Forbes instead of
sending people to forbes.com
something Twitter capitalized early on
and still continues to a very small
little shift that I think has a very big
impact and I hope you digest it and play
around with it today see you later